t'es où on va bientôt passer à table
alors même toit ils en pleine partie de
modern warfare il sait pas sauvegarder
une partie famille c'est toi qui a fait
ça c'est pas moi c'est l'autre des
simples qui a fait ça et puis après les
montées me vois dans ma chambre il n'y a
aucun signe d'effraction
vous êtes certain d'avoir fermé les
portes et les fenêtres sur un certain on
vérifie tous les soirs trois comparateur
de trois zones géographiques différentes
se sont écrasés sur votre maison comme
si quelque chose les années attiré la ba
103 j'ai trouvé l'adresse d'un type
apparemment elle connaît bien le sujet
avez vous eu des malades disent
inexpliquée des pertes de conscience
avez vous l'impression de ne pas
toujours avoir la pleine maîtrise de
votre corps
quand ils seront prêts ils viendront le
chercher
vous devrez passer de porte et surtout
vous ne bougez pas d'ici